-Performing his hit
"Wait in the Truck"
from his number-1 album,
"the mockingbird and THE CROW,"
please welcome HARDY,
featuring Lainey Wilson.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ I got turned around
in some little town
I'd never been to before ♪
♪ Working my way through
a middle-of-June
midnight thunderstorm ♪
♪ There was something in
the headlights ♪
♪ It stopped me on a dime ♪
♪ She was scared to death ♪
♪ So I said, "Climb in, "
and in she climbed ♪
♪ Oh, yeah ♪
♪ She was bruised
and broke from head-to-toe
with a tear in
her blood-stained shirt ♪
♪ She didn't tell the whole
truth, but she didn't have to,
I knew what had happened
to her ♪
♪ I didn't load her down
with questions ♪
♪ That girl
had been through enough ♪
♪ I just threw it in drive,
looked in those eyes,
and I asked her where he was ♪
-♪ I don't know
if he's an angel ♪
♪ 'Cause angels
don't do what he did ♪
♪ He was hell-bent to find
the man behind ♪
♪ All the whiskey scars I hid ♪
♪ And I never thought my day
of justice ♪
♪ Would come from a judge
under a seat ♪
♪ But I knew right then
I'd never get hit again
when he said to me ♪
-♪ "Wait in the truck ♪
♪ Just wait in the truck" ♪
-♪ Well, I knocked and knocked,
and no one came,
so I kicked in his
double-wide door ♪
♪ I let the hammer drop
before he got to that 12
he was reaching for ♪
♪ And I didn't try to hide
my pistol ♪
♪ I didn't even try to run ♪
♪ I just sat on the porch,
smoking one of his cigarettes
and waited for
the cops to come ♪
♪ Yes, I did ♪
-♪ I don't know
if he's an angel ♪
♪ 'Cause angels
don't do what he did ♪
♪ He was hell-bent to find
the man behind ♪
♪ All the whiskey scars I hid ♪
♪ And I never thought my day
of justice ♪
♪ Would come from a judge
under a seat ♪
♪ But I knew right then
I'd never get hit again
when he said to me ♪
-♪ "Wait in the truck ♪
♪ Just wait in the truck" ♪
-♪ Oh ♪
-♪ Have mercy on me, Lord ♪
-♪ Have mercy on me ♪
-♪ Oh ♪
-♪ It's been 60 months,
and she still comes to see me
from time to time ♪
♪ It was worth the price
to see a brighter side
of the girl
I picked up that night ♪
♪ And I might be here forever ♪
♪ It ain't paradise,
that's true ♪
♪ But it's whole hell
of a lot better ♪
♪ Than the place
I sent him to, yeah ♪
-♪ Have mercy, have mercy,
have mercy on me ♪
-♪ Wait in the truck ♪
♪ Just wait in the truck ♪
-♪ Have mercy, have mercy,
have mercy on me ♪
-♪ Wait in the truck ♪
♪ Just wait in the truck ♪
-♪ Have mercy, have mercy,
have mercy on me ♪
-♪ Lord, have mercy on me ♪
-♪ Have mercy, have mercy,
have mercy on me ♪
-♪ Lord ♪
-♪ Have mercy, have mercy,
have mercy on me ♪
♪ Have mercy, have mercy,
-♪ Wait in the truck ♪
♪ Just wait in the truck ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoo!